at the end of the day cultures are
shaped by intellectuals they are uh the
left has dominated the space it's
dominated the space for 100 years if we
really are serious about changing the
world what we need to do is replace the
intellectuals of the left we need to and
it might not be in universities because
we might have to create alternative
University or alternative settings in
which we educate educate people but if
we Congress doesn't matter at the end of
the day what matters is the culture and
and and we need to have an impact on the
culture and if we can't then we lose and
if we can then we will win and the
politics will take care of themselves
but our focus and our obsession with
politics I think diverts our tension
from the real issue and the real
problem all right yon Brook from the
Iran Brook show the chairman of the
board of the iron ran Institute an old
friend absolutely and a man who fled
America for tax purchases not America
it's still America oh it's still it's
still America fled the mainland you fled
the mainland of America for tax purposes
because you actually do live the ideals
that you that you talk about in terms of
limited government and keeping what's
yours and all of that
stuff but let's talk about the state of
the world because the other the other
part of this is that you were born in
Israel uh most of your family still
lives in Israel obviously we're three
weeks into this this
situation take it from there yeah I mean
it's it's it's just hor
uh uh everybody in Israel is being
touched by this there's not a family in
Israel that is not does not either have
a a victim from this in their own family
or they know people who have or friends
or cousins we all have everybody who is
Israeli I think has um has been touched
by this um the tragedy of it is all this
was preventable the tragedy of this is
that
um netan this government you know has
failed the Israeli people for 20 years
now um this should not be a surprise
that hamas's barbarians should not be
surprised to
anybody um the Hamas is part of a wider
Network a wider movement uh Al-Qaeda is
part of that Network Isis is part of
that nwork is part of that nwork and of
course it all in in some sense has a
gravitational Pole from Iran that's
that's the Hub in the center this is all
part of a bigger story that started I
think for most Americans 911 for some of
us even before that uh and it all ties
together with 9/11 with Iran with
everything that's happened over the last
really since 1979 the rise ofi and it's
kind of sad that people don't see the AR
and they don't see necessity to deal
with it because if we don't deal with it
it's just going to happen again it's
these things are just going to reoccur
there is a civilizational battle going
on and we we you know are uh ignoring it
and evading it and uh and doing
everything we can to pretend it doesn't
it's not real do do you think this might
be the wakeup called that the West needs
I mean it's a little early for that
because there's still such chaos and War
and hostages and everything else but I
do sense even from just being here at
ARC people are now talking about this
stuff in a new way there's people a lot
of people in London concerned with what
the Homegrown problem here I mean you
can see at least there seems to be some
shift psychologically no sadly I mean
don't come to you usually for good well
I'd like to be really real at some point
I'd like to be kind of The Optimist in
the room but the reality is I I've been
around you know I was very active after
911 I I did a lot of University talks I
was active after during the uh Danish
cartoon crisis which people have already
forgotten about uh and and this feels
the same after 9911 all the flags came
out and and we went to war and we did
nothing we really did nothing we didn't
deal with the problem uh you know George
Bush and and everybody after every
single Administration since refused to
name the enemy they still talk about
Hamas as if it's some abstraction Hamas
what is Hamas nobody talks about the
fact that it's an Islamic jihadist
motivated by a religion a particular
interpretation of religion not all
Muslims but a particular interpretation
of religion until we're willing to say
the enemy is islamism the enemy is a
totalitarian Islam however fash you know
Islamic fascism however we want to call
it we will not deal with the problem and
we're not going to deal with the you can
already see the extent to which Israel
is coming under criticism it's only
started when the ground operation gets
full you know really gets into full gear
a lot of Palestinians are going to die a
lot of Palestinians have already died
many more are going to die with every
Palestinian death the pressure from the
West on Israel to stop is going to
increase nobody in the west is willing
to deal with what the problem is yes we
we've got an entire fleet of American
ships now in the Western Mediterranean
or Eastern Mediterranean my guess is
they'll do you know they'll do some
defensive stuff they'll shoot down
missiles good for them um but the real
enemy is Iran nobody is talking about
going after Iran and actually doing
what's necessary the Real Enemy isbah if
anything the Biden Administration and
almost everybody's telling is oh no you
can deal with both situations at the
same time so no all I see is hesitancy
the same kind of hesitancy I saw after
911 so what what what would it look like
actually for the West to do whatever it
is you would want them to do what what
actually is that because it seems to me
there's two things there's the
geopolitical problem in the Middle East
obviously now but there's also the
problem we have in our own borders and
it's I me again just being in London for
two days it's very obvious here you
can't deal with a problem in your own
borders unless you recognize that you're
political issue uh so I believe that the
West the free countries of the world
should get together you're not going to
use the UN for this so you have to do
the free countries of the world need to
get together and declare war literally
declare war an access of allies
declaring war on uh Islamic
totalitarianism and that includes that
would include a long list I said this
after 911 so I'm just repeating myself
right Iran and then all the
organizations Affiliated from from
Al-Qaeda Isis Hamas Islamic Jihad and
the rest of them and they need declare
war on that and basically under the
declaration of war you can say if you're
a sympathizer if you're working on their
behalf if then that is now now we can
kick you out we can restrict your
ability to protest we can restrict you
but you can't do that unless you declare
war you can't say yeah we're for Free
Speech but this speech we don't like
right now but you can like in America
when you declared war on the Nazis you
could restrict activity of Nazis in
America when uh you know you're even in
a cold war with the Soviet Union you can
say membership of the Communist party
that's put you have to make a
declaration and then say you know if
you're in in London and you support
Hamas you're not welcome here anymore
and uh we will we will if you're not a
citizen will extradite you and if you
are a citizen you know that you might be
Tred for treason is the inherent problem
that it doesn't seem like the West just
has the stomach to do what's right I
sense maybe if we got the right
Administration in America we might be a
little more willing to do it but it's
almost like the ship has sailed from a
Europe from a Western European I mean
yeah but it's sales in America as well
there is no right Administration I don't
believe there is any Administration that
would be willing to do this
this requires the kind of action this
would certainly more inclined than no I
mean Trump did abandon Muslim
immigration so he banned all the Muslims
from countries that are not threat to
the United States right he didn't ban
Muslims from Saudi Arabia God forbid we
say anything negative about Saudi Arabia
or we criticize the Saudis so he was
very selective in his Banning not to be
too politically not to upset the people
over there that he wants to be friends
with you know his first trip overseas
was to Saudi Arabia where he dashed with
the princess in a in a Despicable
display of just like every American
president what that glowing ball what
what you know remember they had they put
their hand on that glowing ball what the
hell was that they don't even know right
I mean Obama was criticized because he
bowed to the to the Saudi to the Saudis
Trump danced with the Saudis they all do
something with the Saudis and then Biden
pretended to be tough on the Saudis when
he first came in and then within a few
months he he was over there you know
kissing the ring so um no I mean I don't
think the West has the courage I don't
think America has the courage I don't
think America knows what it represents I
I you know
sadly particularly Trump I don't think
understands America maybe somebody like
Des santis um or Nikki Haley or or any
one of those I think have a better
understanding of what America is and
what it stands for you have to have a
huge amount of self-esteem you have a a
huge amount of esteem in America believe
in its values know what they are which
is a big issue right because Americans
don't and be willing to accept domestic
resistance and stand up to the world
because you're going to get World
resistance and you stand up to the Saudi
stand up to a lot of people in the world
and I just don't see an American leader
capable of doing that look it's not that
I blame the leadership at the end of the
day we've talked about this I think in
the past right you get the leaders you
deserve we get the politicians we
deserve at the end of the day this is a
cultural issue it's an educational issue
as long as American culture doesn't
understand what America is
um then you you can't expect this
leadership to Buck the culture to to to
to stand up to the culture you know no
leader is going to lead from a from the
position of I'm opposed the dominant
culture in my own country so what we
need is still to do what we continue to
do which is try to educate people try to
change people's minds and we'll get down
the road that someday we'll get the
right kind of political
leadership I but it's not well if we do
a job right I mean at the end of the day
cultures are shaped by intellectuals
they are uh the left has dominated the
space it's dominated the space for 100
years if we really are serious about
changing the world what we need to do is
replace the intellectuals of the left we
need to and it might not be universities
because we might have to create
alternative University or alternative
settings in which we educate educate
people but if we Congress doesn't matter
at the end of the day what matters is
the culture and and and we need to have
an impact on the culture and if we can't
then we lose and if we can then we will
win and the politics will take care of
themselves but our focus in our
obsession with politics I think diverts
our tension from the real issue and the
real problem when you see the rot that
is now fully exposed at our University I
mean I know you've been talking about
this for a long time one of the things I
was always so impressed when I was doing
a lot of events with the Iran Institute
was that everyone really took ideas
seriously there was a real commitment to
debating ideas to Bringing on people I
mean you guys were always getting me to
bring on people that that calter to your
ideas and clearly that has not happened
at universities but are you still like
the level of insanity right now in the
last couple weeks it's shocking to me
even though I knew it was right there
are are you shocked at all or it's just
like very obvious the extent of it the
the the influence it's had and and the
willingness now to say murder and rape
and beheading of children is okay yeah
if if it's in the right cause postc
colonialism it's as long as you do to
think we meant by decolonization yeah
this is what they meant and so the
extent of it and the the viciousness of
it is is somewhat surprising but but not
really when you think about it right
this was inevitable this is where it
leads there will be a backlash against
this American culture will rebel against
it the American culture fundamentally is
not yet ready quite to embrace that
nuttiness I've always thought that the
ultimate slide towards authoritarianism
in America will not come from the left
because the left is too
insane for the American people to
actually embrace it it will have to come
from that's interesting no I think I
think I think the left will never
dominate in America it might in Europe
but it will never dominate in America it
it'll dominate The Universities for a
while but the the backlash again they
don't know what's coming it of the back
so it can sort of dominate culturally
but not necessarily fully politically
well there's a sense in which look
there's essent what what does it mean to
dominate culture it means it means that
they diminish the role of reason where
they've already done that they elevate
emotion identitarian politics they've
elevated identitarian politics but you
see the kind of emotion the kind of
nihilism and the kind of ad tarianism
that they advocate for nobody's going to
buy and it's never going to be a
majoritarian perspective but once you
unleash that out of the bottle right
once you unleash that Genie of it it's
Teran as of emotionalism
authoritarianism somebody will exploit
it m and it might not be somebody they
like now you know when not to make this
a comparison but history does does see
see some parallels you know when Hitler
came to power the dominant the dominant
culture in uh Germany was left it was
the V of TR Republic was dominated by
the left they were more Communists than
they were fascists but Hitler was so
good at what he did he coal lasted the
Communist on his side he coal lasted
that left it ideology on his sight
because again they Unleashed
emotionalism
authoritarianism uh and he exploited
that and I fear that we are heading
towards some kind of authoritarian who
will wrap himself with a flag he might
wrap himself with religion I don't know
I mean it's likely because you think it
would be someone from the right though
that would grab the political power yes
but yes but it will be the same outcome
and look right left I don't know what
they mean in right I mean I don't I
don't I used to think of myself somewhat
under the right and I don't I you know I
my my view of the political spectrum is
individualism collectivism and
collectivism you've got lots of
different types some of them are the
right some of them are the left some of
them are the center you've got lots of
different types of collectivism
individualism they're not a lot of us
and that's the fundamental battle it's
individualism versus collectivism and
and uh unfortunately the left and right
both seem to be drifting towards
collectivism what do you think we can do
from an American perspective just sort
of I I do think we have some protections
because we do our states are so
different our foundational documents are
better I mean is there anything else we
can do besides expose some of this stuff
and hope that the people start waking up
well I think exposing some of the stuff
is a big part of it but maybe more
important what we can do is um is of an
alternative and it shouldn't be hard in
America because the alternative is
basically the found fathers the found
fathers of America are the alternative
to what's the insanity going on today
it's it's a it's a vision of Liberty
it's a vision of individualism it's a
vision of the pursuit of happiness but a
Pursuit of Happiness Guided by as
Jefferson would say reason and um it it
it is a it is a vision of separation of
church State fine you can have any
religion you want go for it but just
don't impose it on me um and and so Our
Roots the Roots of of uh of America are
in the enlightment are in the in the
Declaration are in the Constitution if
we can Resurrect The Spirit of the
founders if we can bring back and that's
a positive vision and I think that
that's true of Europe Europe needs to
needs to ReDiscover its own roots in the
enlightenment it needs to ReDiscover
John Lock and uh and Adam Smith and the
the thinkers the Scottish Enlightenment
monsue and the French Enlightenment
voler D I mean these are the great
thinkers that I think made the West the
West they made America and they made
Europe this is the right here is the
foundation of Western civilization was
sitting right now in London and and but
you know Scotland and uh and France this
is the axis that made the West the west
and uh these are the ideas that need to
re resurrected we don't have to I think
we need to improve on those ideas but we
don't have to reinvent the wheel the
foundations are here and uh and so that
is the positive Vision a positive vision
of progress of economic growth of to put
in economic terms of of you know um Mara
Jon just published this uh uh that he's
a v of capitalist published this uh
techno up IST Manifesto that's great we
need to embrace stuff like that
something you know things about how
wonderful the future can be if we get
rid of this identitarian nonsense if we
get rid of this emotionalism that has
dominated our our our culture and our
politics and if we focus on what we're
capable of doing what we're capable of
producing well that's exactly what Ark
is doing right now that's why we're here
and uh it's good to be in the five of
you my friend and and I actually
finished on an optimistic note you did
it was a miracle and
communication if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell